if you're looking for ways to
persistently take action with confidence
then this video is for you
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in the potential you have
inside you that I want to see explode
out into the world one of the questions
I get asked a lot is how do I keep on
it's so hard to be an entrepreneur how
do I persistently take action and be
confident in doing so and so today I'm
going to share with you my seven ways to
persistently take action with confidence
so way number one is make sure you're
doing something every single day and so
this is something I took from Jerry
Seinfeld he had the momentum chart where
he would have a calendar and put an X on
the calendar every time he took action
on something and the ideas don't break
the chain don't break the chain you
never want to break the chain so that
every day you're doing something I'm a
big believer in momentum and I think
that as long as you're doing something
every single day to grow your business
some days it might be just sending one
email might be just five minutes on the
company and some days there might be
hours and hours and hours the entire
night trying to really get some momentum
going for you but I think it's really
hard to when you take a day off to then
get back on the horse you might be able
to after you've develop the discipline
but especially at the beginning try not
to break a day and so you may not always
be able to spend the amount of time that
you want but as long as you can do one
minor activity to just check the box so
just put that X on the calendar I think
it really helps build the pattern so
example I like to share is I like to do
30 minutes of biking in the morning I'm
not I was able to do it on a day like
today we have to come in too early to
film videos I can't do it unless I
wanted to wake up earlier which I'm not
willing to do so that's not that I can
I'm just not willing catch those
limiting beliefs and so he did 25
push-ups in the morning 30 seconds to do
it
and then I'm off and I can still for me
I check the box of I did a workout it's
not what I want to do it's not ideal but
I still unable to check out that box and
so the key to be able to take per system
action is to be persistent and take
action the more you built the habit of
doing it and
even if it's just a micro thing it helps
you believe that you can and continues
the momentum chain if you miss a day
especially if you miss two days or more
then it's really hard to get back on the
train they're taking that action so
don't miss a day even if it's taking a
tiny step way number two is to know your
one word having the self-awareness to
understand what it is that you stand for
right here in the book I'm a believe and
so knowing that this is what I stand for
every day when I wake up I remind myself
I remember self what believe is our mind
my self how it breaks down to the Credo
of passion of self confidence of impact
and I look at that and it's inspiring
you know I don't wake up every day
coming out of bed and like everything's
amazing oh my god what a beautiful day
you know I wake up and I'm tired
you know wiping my eyes you know just I
just woke up maybe some people are like
that they just fire it up immediately
but for me it takes me a little bit of
time to get into it so understanding my
core value understanding the kind of
person that I want to be really helps me
get up and start taking some action so
if you don't have the self awareness if
you don't understand your values if you
don't know what you stand for what you
stand against if you don't know the
person who you want to be then it's easy
to do nothing so having that clarity
allows you to take action
when number three is remember your why
when you have a big mission when you're
on an important journey it's just so
much easier to get up and do something
about it you know I make videos because
I want to have an impact on you guys I
learn from them myself
I love watching the successful
entrepreneurs and hearing their mindsets
and the way they think and it always
makes me better and I like making
content that helps you guys grow and
build better businesses and if I feel
like if I can have a tiny impact on your
businesses then you're off doing amazing
things that's that's huge impact and so
remembering that gets me to take action
consistently as well gets me to follow
through waking up today early to come
here and film these videos for you guys
it's not because I love standing in
front of lights and send in front of a
camera with Jason in the room my
cameraman it's because of the result
it's because thousands hundreds of
thousands millions of people are gonna
watch these videos and I know that
that's a big impact and so if I don't
wake up
and I don't come here and I don't do
that don't do the filming then I'm not
having the impact that I want to have
and so remembering your why again I
don't wake up super excited I wake up I
don't remember what I'm trying to do
today I write down my goals that really
helps me take persistent action way
number four is upgrade your routine one
of the things that I find really
difficult at least for me and for others
that I know is waking up and having to
make decisions it's really hard every
day to wake up and decide to do
something big it's really hard to wake
up and have to make a bunch of choices
we have choice fatigue as soon as you
use up all your brain energy to make
choices then you don't have as much
energy to make choices for the rest of
your day and so what I want to do is
wake up every day and just fall into my
routine I fall into my routine this is
the thing that I do every single morning
and that sets me up for success a
challenge you look at what do you do
every morning what are the what's the
routine what's the first thing that you
do and before you leave to get to your
office or go to your home office or get
to work from the time you wake up to the
moment that you're leaving you're ready
to work what are the things that you're
doing what are the habits that are in
there right are you listening to a
podcast are you watching a video are you
reading books are you meditating are you
hugging your cat on the balcony are you
praying like what are the things that
you need to do to make you feel bold and
confident and unstoppable because you've
all felt those moments you've had
moments of boldness an unstoppable miss
understand what led to that what
triggered that and then put that in your
morning routine because if you wake up
and then you do this routine and you do
it everyday and it makes you feel bold
and unstoppable when you're feeling that
power you're gonna want to take action
when you watch that inspiring video
you're gonna want to do something when
you read a page from the book you're
gonna want to take some action on it and
so what I love doing is not having to
convince myself every morning to do
something I just fall into it because
I've created a morning routine that sets
me up for success so I highly highly
highly highly encourage you to value
what your morning routine looks like
stop waking up like an accident and do a
morning routine that has a lot of
intention built in
we number five has changed your
environment this relates to the routine
as well when you're an environment that
motivates you and inspires you you're
more likely to just want to do work when
you're an environment that is negative
and depressing it's a lot harder you can
force yourself to do work but on the
days where you don't have a strong will
you're less likely to do so and so I
strongly encourage you to look at what
is your environment where are you
actually working does it inspire you to
do great things and if not how can you
upgrade or change it so if you look at
my home office where I do a lot of my
work day-to-day it's inspiring I have
pictures of people on the wall that may
mean nothing to you or maybe people you
don't even like but to me it inspires me
I want to walk into there and and I just
get inspired to want to work harder and
again I don't have to think about it I
hope to do anything I just walk in and I
get inspired to work and so whatever
that looks like for you okay you're not
gonna have a mansion on the water that
you can walk it onto the balcony and
just do that amazing work okay you're
not there yet that's fine but what can
you put in your office where your desk
is or can you go to a coffee shop or
library or a co-working space I just
understand what the environment needs to
be for you to be having a great day and
then build that environment for yourself
another example for me I love natural
light and I hate fluorescent lights when
I took over TDS here everything was
fluorescent lights I had to rip it all
out put in other lights that we're not
fluorescent whatever the other versions
are incandescent incandescent LED I
don't know anyway they're not they're
not fluorescent and so I can actually
come to my studio without getting a huge
headache
I love getting natural light so my home
office I have a lot of natural light
right where my desk is I love being able
to see here natural light coming in from
outside this is not a green screen this
is actually where my studio is and those
are real people walking by that's a hack
for myself
some people may love working in a cube
with no windows that's awesome I figure
out what the environment is that allows
you to want to be motivated to work and
then design that so that you're spending
one day creating your great environment
and then every other day waking up and
doing the work
we're number six is commit to someone
when you commit to somebody else you're
more likely to follow through if you
have a 9:00 a.m. meeting with somebody
you're more likely to be there then if
you're just coming into yourself and
that's a challenge for entrepreneurs
because we don't have a boss it's all
I'm asked to be able to do something and
yes we have customers and we're working
deadlines to help them but there's
nobody hovering over you saying you need
to show up and be here on time and so as
an example when I was doing my gratitude
stream I was trying to build a habit of
gratitude for myself everybody talked
about I wanted to build a hack for
myself and see if it worked in trying to
build a morning routine of gratitude I
created a gratitude livestream on my
channel for a while I was on my main
channel then I moved it to my live
channel and eventually I stopped it
because it didn't need the
accountability but knowing that 9:00
a.m. every day I was gonna have this
gratitude live stream or 8:30 or
whatever it was forced me to be there
because I committed to you guys that I
would be there and I would feel really
bad if I didn't show up if you guys all
showed up waiting for me to be there and
I didn't show up that would that would
kill me and so every single day or at
least during the weekdays I went and I
did it and so committing to somebody
else means you're more likely to follow
through consistently so that could be an
online buddy that could be another
entrepreneur buddy that you have it
could be a best friend it could be
anybody in your life or it could be
somebody online that you're looking for
accountability buddy with maybe people
here in the comments believe nation will
be willing to be accountability buddies
for each other when you have somebody
that you're committing to you're much
more likely to follow through and be
consistent because we let ourselves down
much more than we'll let other people
dare
anyway number seven is just to do what
you love and this is cliche but it's a
number-one rule in the book top ten was
a success it's the most common thing
that people say who've achieved massive
success you kind of do the thing that
you love if you're doing work that you
love you're more likely to follow
through you're more likely to do it
because it doesn't feel like work
because you love doing it I love
thinking about my youtube channel I love
thinking about trying to dance also I
love thinking about Lily in her business
I love thinking about the investments
that I'm making in different companies I
love thinking about the big vision of
where I'm going I love doing it so it's
not work it's not a chore if you wake up
and you see this list of things that you
have to do and you just think man this
sucks I can't wait for this day to be
over
if that's everyday that's not a great
life like that means you need to change
what you're doing because you can only
force yourself to do something that you
don't like for so long before you give
up and quit you will never achieve
amazing success you'll never be the best
at what you do you never be happy if
you're constantly doing work that you
hate because the people who love doing
that work will destroy you and so better
to eliminate that as soon as you can and
move towards a path of doing work that
you actually love so those are my seven
ways on how to persistently take action
with confidence I'd love to know which
of the seven had the biggest impact on
you that you resonate the most with or
thought you need to work on a little bit
for yourself then I miss an 8 9 10 that
you want to add to the list leave it
down in the comments below I'm really
curious to hear from you I made this
video because me Jin choy asked me to so
if there's a topic you'd like me to
cover in a future seven ways video check
out the description for a request line
you can go and cast your vote and I just
might do it and finally I want to give a
quick thank you to Mike Markham from
restaurant HR thank you so much Mike for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word posting a picture I really
appreciate the support man and I'm so
glad you enjoyed the book so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is much love I'll see you soon
yeah the most important work ever if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be kind of like a little
beacon hey believe nation if you want to
know what the most important one word is
for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details